[Music]
so chuck how often do you think about
pollution
quite a bit honestly i mean
you know
i have because you're a green guy
you're a green guy one guy i think about
it quite a bit and and and the uh
deleterious effect that is having on our
uh our existence
our ecosystem so
so not all pollution is made of plastic
so
very early on
the astronomers of the world
have complained about light pollution
when you had the electrification of the
cities
all of a sudden
the night sky was competing
with lights that were shedding photons
up into the atmosphere
and i grew up in a city so i had no
understanding of the night sky until my
first visit to the hayden planetarium at
age nine nice and i know it was nice and
i looked up and the lights dimmed and
the stars came out i said this before
i'll say it again i thought it was a
hoax way too many stars
how that is up there i don't know what
this is i'll go along with it for now
but stop trying to pull my leg next time
i come back show it how it really is
fake names fake news
it was totally fake news right and
and to this day from mountaintops when
i've gone to
high level mountaintops with high level
telescopes i look up at the night sky
and i say it reminds me of the hayden
planetarium
that's an urban
urban frame of reference urban frame of
reference that was so plus i'm old
enough to remember what not only was
there light pollution as there still is
but back then there was also air
pollution
and today we think of the polluting the
atmosphere with carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide is transparent so that's not
what i was thinking at the time
i was thinking auto exhaust and
and this sort of thing so not only did
lights but auto exhaust disrupt your
ability to see all objects in the night
sky especially the dimmest objects
and we should do a whole explainer on
noise of all kinds so remind me to do
this yes but let me let me just say if
you can if you're in a perfect dark
night and you can just barely see a very
dim star
and then other light gets added to this
the first things to go are the dimmest
stars so you start hacking away at the
dimmest things available to you simply
because other light is competing with it
and it no longer shows up in on your
retina or even in a in a camera
so these are problems
and so
we've been living with this like our
whole lives in fact there's something
called the ida international id
international international dark sky
association okay they sound like a group
of super villains
the idea that's all i'm saying
[Laughter]
that's all i can tell you about them yes
exactly
so we've called this meaning of the
international dark sky association
to finalize our plans to permanently
block out the sun
that is true dark skies for everyone 24
hours a day like that's so funny
i've never heard of that
and how much will it cost it will cost a
million dollars
sir i just want to let you know that's
not a lot of money these days okay
five million
what's the inflation rate how how much
should we ask for should we ask for
something more
did he had with that whole conversation
in the movie i think so it was i don't
know how it went to be honest but it was
something like that just like
and how much now is it
so they that organization has gotten
more and more powerful and more
power not in a let's override you
but there's a lot of interesting
sensible things to do for example
let's say you're in an airplane and
you're flying over a city and you look
down you see the suburbs and you see the
street lights illuminating
the streets right at night from your
airplane right do you know why you can
see the street light
because it's
bright i don't know
because somebody in that town is paying
for electricity to go into this lamp to
generate photons that are going up in to
the through the window of my airplane i
got you so i got you like a lantern the
lights going everywhere everywhere not
directed you don't need the light
everywhere do you watch it on this
street if i see your light it means you
are paying to illuminate my airplane
flying overhead
if you can see any light at all
directly from its source somebody's
paying to illuminate the sky right so
the ida simply makes the economic
argument do you want to save money okay
so you put a little hat on each lamp
well that's adorable now wait a minute
and make it reflective so hey
that light that used to be going upwards
is now coming downwards and i don't need
that much light
i was wasting half of it right so now i
can cut the wattage in half or by
whatever fraction right use less light
and now i'm not illuminating the
airplanes flying overhead it's that
simple
and that's why we don't do it
because it's that it's simple because
and anything that simple we just can't
do it which can't wrap our head so the
town of tucson arizona which is proximal
to
kitt peak mountain which has kid peak
observatory which is one of the major
observatories of the nation's
astronomers long ago came into an
agreement with the municipal leaders to
say
look i can if you're if your place keeps
getting brighter we can't do our science
we got to move our base because the home
base is in town where all the scientists
hang out before they go to the mountain
and so but they like this distinction
plus arizona is beautiful and it's got
deserts and you know so why not preserve
it all and so they got together and
their ordinances city ordinances that
control how bright the lights can be how
what what kind of hat should be on them
when you should turn them off
all of this
and so
that was successful that became a model
for other towns to emulate
and so that's the light pollution and
and like they said the air pollution is
essentially gone relative to when i was
growing up when i was growing up i'd
come home from school from elementary
school you could brush the ash off your
shoulders okay from incinerated garbage
that had gone into the sky and descended
back to earth that is just crazy it was
snowing garbage snowing ash correct
every every day that's
amazing yeah yeah so now so that's that
but we have more pollution than that
right wait let me just say this about
the light pollution that i just thought
about right now because of what you just
said
uh when they were building the big
hotels in atlantic city of course i'm
from philly so atlantic city they were
building these giant hotels um
and
uh the conservationists
uh in the area the scientists that you
know care for animals and sea life and
birds
they
basically realize that you're killing
all the birds because they never know
that it's nighttime
yeah and people okay so at least i
didn't lose my at least i didn't lose my
life over this
yeah
wow so the bird just completely
disrupting all of their
everything they they have worse no more
circadian rhythm and they were flying
until and they were dying of exhaustion
and all kinds of crazy stuff it was it
was a weird little study that they did
but
i don't know what they did about it
because they haven't changed anything
but i think the consensus from the
public was they're seagulls who gives a
crap
[Laughter]
she goes in pigeons right we've got
plenty of those pigeons plenty more of
them where they came from you want us to
care about that dirt i mean first of all
we could see if they were chickens
they're delicious but
it was terrible it was terrible so chuck
is not only light pollution that worries
astronomers
when we think of light you think of like
visible light right but we don't only
use visible light to communicate with
the universe or to receive the universe
we also have radio waves
huge radio telescopes okay
well wait a minute we have tv
right you know am fm satellite microwave
all those are in the radio parts of the
spectrum so not only is there light
pollution with visible light
that interferes your eyes from seeing
dim objects there's radio wave pollution
that prevents our radio telescopes from
seeing dim objects
right
so other bands of the electromagnetic
spectrum are also polluted and so our
best radio telescopes have to be put in
places where there's like a radio free
zone around it
all right just so that we don't get
noise radio noise coming in disrupting
our observations of radio galaxies the
microwave background of the formation of
the universe and all of this well there
you go people cool it on the hot pockets
microwave okay take it easy on the hot
pockets people and you know what else uh
the remote fobs for cars right also
creates a background noise of radio
waves wow
to a radio telescope that is extremely
sensitive
so uh leaving the realm of light in that
sense there's also a new kind of
pollution called satellite pollution oh
my gosh
and so what happens here is
the effect of this is the satellite is
moving across your field of view and
it's reflecting sunlight so you get a
streak
so other parts of your photo might be
okay but suppose that street goes to the
one object you're trying to look at
right so you need a way to sort of
subtract it out from the process we have
people working on software to accomplish
that right now we don't know how this is
all going to shake out in the coming
years so we're pre-loading
our our data reduction utilities just to
try to subtract them out i i'm told i
just attended a a workshop on on
satellite pollution where there was an
agreement with elon musk for some of his
satellites to use a a sunshade
okay right so even though they're up
there they will the the sun the sun will
not reflect off of it down to us and it
did improve the seeing conditions
it did improve it
but i think the whatever might be a
long-term solution to this has not yet
arrived
so that that's what we're in the middle
of now
that is kind of crazy
and the current most powerful telescope
on earth okay is called the vera rubin
telescope and it is designed to take
movies
of the night sky every single night that
is pretty dope okay because think about
it up until now we've been taking just
snapshots okay so if the thing did
something different an hour later after
you're on the way back to the computer
you missed it tough time
you missed it missed out okay
uh so it's taking a movie so that
it's called um
uh there's an entire branch of my field
that concerns itself with things that
change over time
right because most images you're seeing
is just a static picture of something
right so the people who care about stuff
that's changes in the universe
this will be a delight for them and but
now that we're taking movies we
basically have movies of all these
satellites crossing our field of view
and we have to distinguish between that
and what might be a killer asteroid
moving across the field of view because
this has an asteroid alert system built
in
wow
so
without i mean this sounds more
important than it might appear
because this ain't just looking at a
telescope and going what is that oh
that's some little elon musk junk don't
worry about it
and then it ends up being a killer
asteroid yeah what is that oh that's a
killer asteroid that we almost mistook
for an elon musk satellite right right
yeah right
so yeah that's what we're confronting
with right now
the the buckets of pollution that
influence the modern astrophysicist
knows no bounds wow and none of it has
anything to do with plastic or carbon
dioxide what do you think of that well
what we should have is an astrophysicist
standing next to a rocket with a single
tear rolling down
[Laughter]
that'll be a public service announcement
all right right
i'll volunteer i'll be the tiering
astrophysicist for that
space pollution you only you can stop
spacecraft space pollution
all right chuck that's all the time we
got all right that was great all right
the pollution the astronomers edition on
star talk yet another explainer video
neil degrasse tyson keep looking up
[Music]
you